tras un largo debate de la comisión de
constitución del Congreso de Perú
rechazó el proyecto de adelanto de
elecciones en la presidenta Dina
boluarte el ministro de Justicia José
Tello sustentó la iniciativa acompañado
de los jefes de organismos electorales
pero los congresistas con once votos a
favor y diez en contra desestimaron la
propuesta y la enviaron al archivo es
así que el proyecto de la presidenta
boluarte que propone el adelanto de
electoral para octubre de 2023 no se
verá sino hasta finales del mes de julio
o los primeros días de agosto cuando el
congreso de este país inicie otra
legislatura con este se contabilizan ya
cuatro proyectos de ley que son
rechazados por el parlamento esta
situación lo que va a hacer es complicar
más la crisis política y social que
sufre Perú según una encuesta del
instituto de estudios peruanos el 73% de
la población está a favor de que las
elecciones se realicen este año y en
cuanto a la desaprobación del gobierno y
el parlamento el 76% de encuestados
desaprueba la gestión de Dina Mientras
que el 89% de la población rechaza la
labor real congreso según algunos
analistas la negación del parlamento a
la reforma electoral debilita más al
gobierno de la presidenta Dina boluarte
y aumentará el descontento social